Now that we have seen how TLB's work,
let's do a quiz on TLB performance.
Suppose we have a program with a 1 MB
array that it reads one byte at a time
from start to end and this start
to end read happens ten times.
So ten times we sweep
through the array reading it.
Suppose also that no other memory,
other than this 1 MB array,
is accessed during this time.
Suppose that the processor has a 4kB
page size, and a level one TLB that
has 128 entries, and
a level two TLB with 1,024 entries.
And the TLBs are initially empty,
they have no translations cached
when we begin the first read.
The array, here, is page aligned,
meaning the array
begins at the beginning of a page and
the TLBs are direct mapped.
The question for you is, in the level
one TLB, we have how many hits and
how many misses, and in the level two
TLB how many hits and how many misses?